okay so we're given this line 2x minus
3y equals 12 and we're given this point
6 1 and we want to find the equation of
line that's perpendicular to it and goes
through this point so I'm going to show
you two different methods and just a
quick refresher we've got our two forms
of the equation aligned here y equals MX
plus B as well as the point-slope form
I'll show you both methods the first
thing you want to do though is if we
have a line we want to find a line
that's perpendicular to it the first
thing we have to do is find the slope of
that original line so to do that we're
going to rewrite it in the
slope-intercept form by getting Y by
itself so we're going to subtract 2x
from both sides of the equation so that
gives us negative 3y equals negative 2x
plus 12 we're gonna divide everything by
negative 3 because we want to get that Y
by itself so you can see we're getting y
equals positive 2/3 because the two
negatives cancel y equals 2/3 X minus 4
okay so now we can see that our slope is
that number that's in front of the X and
if we want to find the slope of the
perpendicular line we're gonna have to
take the opposite reciprocal meaning
that we're gonna have to change the sign
and we're gonna have to flip that
fraction but we don't know the B value
we don't know where it crosses the
y-axis but that's why they give us this
point 6 1 so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna put the 6 in for X and the 1
in for y so that we can solve for our
y-intercept so we can solve for our B
value so here we've got 1 equals
negative three-halves times 6 which is
like 6 over 1 plus B so this gives us
negative 18 over 2 which is negative 9
and if we add 9 to both sides of the
equation you can see that B is coming
out to positive 10 so now we just have
to put that back in and we've got our
equation of our perpendicular line y
equals negative 3 halves X plus 10 now
you're probably saying Mario when this
be a lot easier if I just use the
point-slope form and you can certainly
do that let's go ahead and do that we've
got our point which is 6 1 so you put
one in for Y and 6 in for X and then our
slope we figured out was the opposite
reciprocal of 2/3 which is negative 3
over 2 now all you have to do is
distribute the negative 3
haves add the one to their side to get Y
by itself you get the same equation we
did here if you want to learn more about
equations of lines check out the
playlist I put for you right there and
I'll see you over in those videos